appointed to the supreme court as a wise
latina justice sonia sotomayor proves
herself a fool and aoc comes down with
covet after leaving the hellscape of
unmasked miami i'm bench bro this is the
bench bureau show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn why haven't you gotten a vpn
yet visit expressvpn.com
ben we'll get to all the news in just
one moment first here is your reminder
that you are spending an awful lot of
money on your cell phone bill and you
don't need to be did you know you don't
just vote in november you vote every
single month with the money you spend in
the companies you choose to spend it
with if you are still a customer of
verizon or at t or t-mobile you are
choosing to support the candidates and
issues that they donate to you are
funding biden pelosi schumer the leftist
agenda very often these big corporations
are pushing but here i bring you a
solution pure talk see pure talk as i've
said uses the exact same towers the same
5g network as one of those companies but
with the peace of mind that you're
supporting a veteran-run business a
business whose employees are right here
in the united states so yes this is a
monthly bill you can be proud to pay and
it also happens to be a lot lower than
the bill that you would be paying if you
were using one of the big companies it's
about half of what your current cell
phone bill is the average family saves
over 800 a year so head on over to
puretalk.com find the plan that is right
for you find the phone that's right for
you or just bring your own then because
they love my listeners enter promo code
ben shapiro and you'll save 50 off your
very first month of coverage that's
puretalk.com promo code ben shapiro to
get started with my friends over at pure
talk usa alrighty so
over the weekend the supreme court was
out considering whether or not to allow
the biden backs mandates to move forward
and here's the thing whatever case on a
political level there was for a vax
mandate is now gone it does not exist
oh macron has completely obliterated it
and the facts on the ground just do not
even match what the biden administration
was arguing when they were arguing that
they needed a vax mandate for major
employers in the united states with
regard to delta so forget about the fact
that it's unconstitutional forget about
the fact it violates basic strictures of
federalism forget about the fact that
it's not even good policy because
basically all it does
is force people who are more vulnerable
to stay home
but those people then get infected at
home i mean it turns out the chief
vector of transmission in the united
states is not in fact work it's not
airplanes it's not school it is the home
okay but put all of that aside the fact
is that delta the suggestion was that if
you got vaccinated against delta maybe
you'd prevent transmission with omicron
that's not even relevant in fact every
single human is going to get omicron
whether you are vaccinated or not one of
the unfortunates who now has come down
with kovid and it's no longer a moral
test right the way that it was before if
you got covered it was a test of your
strength your faith in the authorities
now if you get covet it's just you know
naturally living life but the
irrepressible
incredibly fresh incredibly faced so
fresh so unbelievably faced aoc has now
tested positive for covet 19 because it
turns out that kova 19 just wanted to
date her and was obsessed with her
boyfriend's feet that's the only reason
that you got kova 19 is because kova 19
really was into her boyfriend's feet
according to the new york post new york
congresswoman aoc has tested positive
for coven 19 she's recovering at home
just over a week since she was spotted
partying without a mask in florida
according to her office on sunday
her statement said representative
ocasio-cortez has received a positive
test result for kova 19 she is
experiencing symptoms and recovering at
home the congresswoman received her
booster shot this fall encourages
everyone to get their booster and follow
all cdc guidance
well she didn't follow cdc guidance when
she went out unmasked in miami did she
and now she's been punished with the
covid here's the thing guys if you get
omicron particularly vaccinated you're
going to be fine so why are we still
talking about shutting down all of
society according to the new york post
the progressive squad member was
photographed with boyfriend riley
roberts sitting outside at the zorako
isakaya and sushi restaurant on december
30th sipping a cocktail checking her
phone
aoc's massless winter getaway was
criticized on social media because of
course she decided to jet set down to
florida where everybody is living free
and easy as opposed to staying up in the
precinct that she has helped make a
lockdown hellscape
the sunshine states lieutenant governor
jeannette nunez chimed in saying aoc's
new york state of mind clearly doesn't
belong in the free state a florida
mask-free of course
and uh there she was hugging everybody
and then she came down with the covid so
obviously covet has come for her but
again the only reason the covet is
interested is because coven wants to
date her now here is the thing the
entire mentality of the left is now
shifting with regard to covid because
now they're getting it when it was just
a bunch of red states getting it then it
was that because they're bad but if they
get it it's because they're good and
omicron is going to hit everyone and
perhaps we should take measures that are
more geared toward
mitigation of some of the worst aspects
of the virus without destroying the
economy you know they're coming to all
the conclusions that many of us came to
back in like may of 2020.
so here's scott gottlieb former fda
commissioner he's been pretty hawkish on
covet he says listen first of all let's
just put it out there this epidemic is
going to be over inside of two weeks
because it's been over everywhere inside
of about a month so it's already peaked
in places like new york and washington
dc
if you look what's happening across the
east coast right now new york city
washington dc maryland probably florida
as well have already peaked maybe
delaware and rhode island you're going
to start to see that in the statistics
this week you're going to start to see
those curves those epidemic curves bend
down you're already seeing that in new
york city in washington d.c
by the way when there's all this talk
about hospitalizations and the increase
in hospitalizations gottlieb noted that
the length of stay is down substantially
so the hospitalizations aren't even the
same as the hospitalizations that were
occurring with delta the average length
of stay used to be four days it is now
1.6 days which means that people are
going to the hospital they're staying
there for like 36 hours and then they're
out
okay even the cdc is beginning to
realize reality according to richelle
willenski quote we must protect people
with comorbidities from severe covenant
19. i went into medicine hiv
specifically and public health to
protect our most at risk cdc is taking
steps to protect those at highest risk
including those with chronic health
conditions disabilities and older adults
wait a second are you saying that we
should shield the most vulnerable and
let everybody else go about their lives
because i seem to remember some people
saying that rather early by the way
remember much maligned sweden how sweden
was the end it was sweden was going to
get everyone killed right their shield
the most vulnerable but everybody else
lived their lives
policy with regard to covet was going to
get everybody killed sweden in 2021
which is a very deadly year around the
globe for covet in 2021 sweden had the
best death rate in terms of covid in
northern europe why because everybody
had natural immunity by the time that
delta actually hit
by the way even wallenski is starting to
relent on on all sorts of aspects of
this it's it's fascinating to watch in
real time as the entire narrative shifts
when all of their friends get covered
we'll get to that in just one second
first work attire has changed fellas
chances are you're not wearing suits and
ties in your office anymore and you know
what that's nice it's a lot more
comfortable but what exactly are you
supposed to wear instead well that's the
problem steven barely set out to solve
when he started a company called cuts in
2016 steven set out to create clothes
ready for every occasion the modern man
faces he started by reinventing the
t-shirt so all i wear are cuts t-shirts
the only t-shirts that i wear are cuts
t-shirts
they're super comfortable they fit
fantastically well the signature buttery
soft custom engineered pika polo tri
blendy it's a bold new take on a classic
design combining the ultimate blend of
high quality cotton polyester and
spandex gq magazine has called it the
only shirt worth wearing because it
really is i mean i'm telling you the
only thing that i wear outside the
office is cuts brand clothing it is just
that good cuts clothing is work leisure
apparel for the sport of business
they've also got great stuff like
they've got zip ups and they've got all
sorts of great gear i just got a new zip
up it's fantastic from cuts get 15 off
your first order by going to
cutsclothing.com
ben that's c-u-t-s
clothing.com for 15
off the only shirt worth wearing
alrighty so
rochelle willenski she is now admitting
that there is a difference between
hospitalization from covid and with
cobit so many people were pointing this
out last year that every time somebody
died the question should have been
whether they died from covet or with
covet because if you were 90 years old
and you had leukemia and then you died
and you had kobe because they tested you
did you die because of the covet or did
you die because of the leukemia and it
happens that you had coveted at the time
and we were told you're not even allowed
to ask these questions well now that the
cases have spiked there are a lot of
people in the hospital particularly
children who are in the hospital not
from covid but with kova there are a lot
of kids who are going to the hospital
with say flu or rsv and then they're
also testing positive for covid which
means they're not there because of the
covet where shoveling was asked about
this he says oh yeah we're gathering
stats on that now weird that you guys
didn't bother gathering stats on this
over at the cdc over the course of the
last two years
do you know how many of the 836 000
deaths in the u.s linked to covid are
from covid or how many are with covid
but they had other co-morbidities do you
have that breakdown
um yes of course with omicron we're
following that very carefully our death
registry of course um takes a few weeks
to
and it takes a few weeks to collect um
and of course omicron has just been with
us for a few weeks but those data will
be forthcoming
oh this data will be fourth i'm glad
that you're collecting them now weird
that you haven't collected them over the
course of the last two years and when
you realize what it is that the cdc has
actually spent money investigating and
what they have not spent money doing or
investigating it really is incredible so
you've had all sorts of studies from the
cdc about racial disparities in
treatment of covet but how many studies
have we had about the actual level of
antibodies in the general population
early on
like how many people have actually had
culver do we even know that why wasn't
the cdc doing any of that why was it
left to private people in like santa
clara county organizing private studies
as to exactly how many people had gotten
covet
well how about the cdc stats and how
many people have gotten this via
transmission on airplanes the cdc has
provided no data like the most practical
aspects of this virus the cdc has
ignored the entire time instead pursuing
specifically political questions and now
that the politics of code have shifted
against the lockdown fanatics now all of
a sudden they're like you know what
maybe we should check out how many
people died of covid versus with covid
it is incredible how much our public
health establishment has blown itself
out the story of the last decade in
american politics is every major
institution in american society
destroying its own credibility on the
strolls of politics it really is
unbelievable everything from the ama to
the educational institutions of our
nation
to the cdc like every single area
that of institutional trust has been
decayed not by skeptics from the outside
but by people from the inside who in
order to fight those skeptics have
completely undermined
all of their credibility and trust it's
it's absolutely insane by the way
rachelle willenski admitted over the
weekend the killer app when it comes to
the joe biden vax mandate if the vax
does not prevent transmission there is
no reason for a vax mandate
and the entire basis for a vaccinate is
that you have to keep the unvaxed away
because the unvacs can infect the vast
or something or they can infect each
other you don't want that happening at
work and that is the entire basis of the
vaccine mandate but if the vaccinate if
the vaccinated can also pass covet that
is completely irrelevant well here was
with shoveling last night admitting that
the vaccines don't actually stop
transmission which of course we all knew
since all of our friends are getting
covered no matter how many times they've
been baxed
um our vaccines are working
exceptionally well they continue to work
well for delta with regard to severe
illness and death they prevent it but
what they can't do anymore is prevent
transmission so if you're going home to
somebody who has not been vaccinated to
somebody who can't get vaccinated
somebody who might be immunosuppressed
or a little bit
frail somebody who has
comorbidities that put them at high risk
i would suggest you wear a mask in
public indoor settings
okay so forever presumably because
omicron is now an epidemic i mean
it is now endemic rather omicron's
everywhere so presumably for the rest of
your life it is just going to be a risk
that is out there so i mean
they've gone completely crazy i mean i
have a 98 year old grandmother and my 98
year old grandmother is uh is in a
facility an assisted living facility
she's she's older and um and they have
locked her in her room like full-on
locked her in her room it doesn't matter
that she's been exposed to coveted 25
times over they've now locked her in her
room even though she is is not immuno
suppressed like at a certain point
you're just gonna have to let people
live because this is what it is that is
the end of the story at least people
should be given the choice as to whether
or not they are allowed to see other
people
it's it's totally crazy at at this point
i mean even brian stelter is mocking the
cdc here's brian stelter over at cnn
going oh wait a second the cdc is bad at
its job so all the i thought this was
questioning the science i thought that
if you mocked the cdc or made fun of
anything the cdc says this is
questioning the science apparently
you're allowed to do so now so it's open
season on all the institutions that we
were banned from even criticizing on
social media for the last year and a
half
here's the today show here's savannah
guthrie interviewing the cdc director
being very much in touch with the public
recognizing the cdc has turned into a
punchline it is so sad but it's true the
cdc has turned into a punchline watch
all of this mixed messages or new
messages has led to a meme on social
media poking fun at the cdc's advice
tweets like cdc now recommends eating
straight off the floor at waffle house
the cdc now says it's in fact okay to
eat tide pods the cdc says go ahead and
get bangs you know it's amusing people
letting off steam's steam of course but
is there a larger credibility problem
with your agency right now
and the answer is yes there's a huge
credibility crisis
i don't know when tucker carlson
inhabited the body of potato brian
stelter but apparently that's a thing
now by the way cnn is now reporting that
rachelle belinsky who's been terrible at
this since the get-go and many of us
have been criticizing her for being
terrible at this since the gecko
rachelle willenski apparently is now in
media training like she literally has to
have people come in and explain to her
how to do media hits which is kind of
incredible for somebody who's the head
of the cdc
cnn has learned dr wolenski is in media
training for months she's been meeting
with a consultant to improve
communication skills the well-regarded
infectious disease expert had no
government experience before president
biden appointed her and has often seemed
out of step with the white house and dr
fauci leading to some abrupt and
confusing changes in guidance now
wallensky is under fire for not
following the cdc's own playbook for
explaining new guidance a biden covet
advisor tells me the cdc has got to do a
better job communicating what they're
doing and why and that has to happen
quickly
okay my favorite thing here is the
president of the united states being the
cdc they're really bad at coms
that's joe biden's white house
joe biden is not even alive
his comms consists of him stumbling out
to a podium saying several sentences in
a row that seem to take the form of
sentences but don't actually have words
that make sense in them sort of like a
lewis carroll parody of grammar and then
stumbling off the stage before taking
any questions he's like we need to get
michelle olinsky some media mechanisms
man you know you've blown it when joe
biden is recommending he gets media
training in just one second we'll get to
the continued panic over omicron which
is not politically driven from the left
we'll get to that in just one second
first 2022 should be a big year for
business right now there is a massive
worker shortage in the united states
this means that if you're an employer
you really need to find a great way to
find great employees and the best way to
do that is to head on over to zip
recruiter right now i mean every
business owner i'm talking to is talking
about how they have a real lack of labor
and how they need more people working
hey well if you're looking for like the
best workers and there aren't enough of
them you need to head on over to zip
recruiter right now right now try it for
free at ziprecruiter.com
dailywire ziprecruiter uses powerful
technology to find and match the right
candidates up with your job then it
proactively presents these candidates to
you
you can easily review these recommended
candidates and invite your top choices
to apply for your job that encourages
them to apply faster no wonder zip
recruit is the number one rated hiring
site in the united states based on g2
ratings zip recruiters technology is so
effective that four out of five
employers who post tons of recruiter get
a quality candidate within the very
first day and right now you can try zip
recruiter for free at this exclusive web
address
d-a-i-l-y w-i-r-e that is zip
recruiter.com
daily wire zip recruiter the smartest
way to hire okay so meanwhile in chicago
it's fun to watch as the democratic
party tears itself apart because half of
the democratic party is still invested
fully in lockdown and half the
democratic party's like guys if we
continue this we're just gonna get
chillacked at the polls so you have the
chicago teachers union now battling it
out with mayor lori lightfoot who is a
lockdown fanatic the chicago public
schools canceled class for the fourth
straight day on monday as negotiations
continued with the chicago teachers
unions according to wls chicago public
school has now canceled classes again
monday marks the fourth straight day cps
students have been out of class mary
laura mayor lori lightfoot spoke
confidently all weekend about reaching a
deal no agreement has been reached
despite both sides negotiating overnight
here's what mayor lori lightfoot had to
say about the chicago's teachers union
that seems to control her administration
what the chicago teachers union did was
an illegal walkout they abandoned their
posts and they abandoned kids and their
families
we are working diligently every single
day at the bargaining table to narrow
the differences and get a deal done my
team has been working on every single
day they're back at it again uh here
sunday they were at it yesterday and we
can get a deal done if there's goodwill
on both sides but fundamentally what we
cannot do is abandon the science we know
that the safest place for kids to be is
learning in school
well welcome to the club lori lightfoot
my god they're all libertarians now it's
incredible in its own statement on
sunday the ctu said quote the union
wants to reassure the parents and
guardians of chicago we will remain at
the bargaining table until we reach an
agreement that will return us all to in
person learning safely and
equitably by equitably they mean not
safely or equitably they just mean we
get what we want this comes after the
union proposed chicago teachers be in
buildings this week handing out digital
devices and signing up students for
covet 19 testing in order to start
remote learning on wednesday with the
goal of returning to in-person
instruction january 18th
january 18th it is currently january
10th by the way so this means that they
just got a two-week vacation teachers
said they want to be in school but they
believe that cps schools need to ramp up
testing like local private schools have
okay well
private schools should not be testing
either the reality is kids are going to
get omicron and we're all going to move
on with our lives because everything is
incredibly stupid by the way if lori
lightfoot really wanted to do something
with the ctu they have this is an
illegal strike she said it's an illegal
walkout should you just say every day
you're not there you're not getting paid
end of story done
and then we'll see how much people like
not being paid and staying out of work
they can do that forever she'll say
we'll get some subs we'll put them in
the classroom we'll hire them from out
of state if need be but we are not going
to have our students sitting home
because you dullards decide that you are
deeply deeply afraid of a virus that is
going to kill precisely none of you
since you're all vast presumably
and meanwhile
controversy continues to surround
novak djokovic novak djokovic of course
is the is the
probably the greatest male tennis player
of all time it's a three-way battle
between him and roger federer and and
rafael nadal and djokovic is on the
verge of becoming the single greatest
major winner of all time and the
australian open was really his best shot
he's 34 years old he that that's the
tournament that he tends to dominate and
so he wanted to head over to australia
and take that title while the australian
authorities were like you need to vax
he's like well hold up i already have
natural immunity plus i'm maybe the
healthiest person on planet earth he
literally tested positive for covid in
december and then he tested negative and
then got a medical exemption and then a
court basically held him up
he got a border travel permit and then
he arrived in melbourne late at night
and then his passport was immediately
taken he was escorted to a small room he
was interviewed by border control
officials his visa was canceled by the
australian government he was taken to a
temporary detention facility at the park
hotel in melbourne and then a judge
decided to quash the cancellation of his
visa
all of this is nuts all of this of
course is totally crazy and australia's
immigration
minister is still thinking about maybe
canceling his visa anyway after the
court said that he could go in again
novak djokovic by the way the cases in
australia are out of control because
omicron cannot be controlled by the
vaccine
and cannot be controlled in terms of its
spread by the vaccine this is perfectly
clear rashel walensky just said it one
second ago but people are still panicked
okay so here is the thing
all of this is relevant to the fact that
the supreme court had a hearing on
friday over joe biden's unconstitutional
vax mandates so there are several
reasons why joe biden's vax mandates are
unconstitutional via osha number one the
enabling statute for osha does not
comprehend the ability of the federal
government to simply do whatever it
wants in workplaces that's not what osha
is for osha was made for regulating the
amount of asbestos in the workplace or
making sure that you are a hard hat if
you work in a factory or something osha
was not meant to
basically reduce all risk in every
public place in american life
simply because there's
a virus out there
nobody ever would have comprehended that
osha could have for example a fluvax
mandate nobody ever would have
comprehended that
the notion of a bax mandate with regard
to workplaces via osha is crazy now
states have plenary authority in this
area states have police power in this
area localities do which makes a lot of
sense because again the basic notion of
american republicanism
a smaller republicanism is that the more
local the government is the more that
government is empowered to do because
you have more homogeneous communities
who agree on more things
and as you abstract the government as it
becomes farther and further away from
the local citizen there's less agreement
which means that the federal government
should do very little and the local
government should do a lot
well the the joe biden vaccinated does
not comprehend that they think that osha
should do whatever it wants even though
the osha statute is incredibly vague
the truth is the osha statute is
probably unconstitutional on its face
just for its vagueness
and so it's unconstitutional for that
reason it violates the precepts of
federalism and it happens to not be
reasonably related to an actual policy
goal since the vaccines were not even
stopping the transmission of delta fully
okay so this came up for a hearing at
the supreme court we're going to get
into all the details in just one second
because it demonstrates how for certain
members of the supreme court the
constitution not only does not matter it
is just completely dispensable it's like
a used mask we'll get to that in just
one second first let's talk about a
fantastic gift you can get for yourself
or your family this year okay i have one
of these it's fantastic okay it is a
portrait of my family created by
paintyourlife.com and get a professional
hand-painted portrait created
from any photo at a truly affordable
price or you can combine photos of
people or places you love into one
painting so if you've got a bunch of
family members all over the country and
they can't even do a photo shoot you can
send pictures of those people to a
painter and that painter will then churn
out a portrait of you and your family
from all over the world it's fast you
can receive your portrait in as little
as two weeks you can send any picture
and they'll turn it into a portrait it
makes the perfect birthday anniversary
or wedding gift it is meaningful
personal it can be cherished forever on
the wall of my home we have a portrait
of me and my wife and two of our three
kids we actually have to get an update
and we plan on doing so asap with the
latest with squishy baby at
paintyourlife.com there is no risk if
you don't love the final painting your
money is refunded guaranteed and right
now as a limited time offer get 20 off
your painting that is correct 20 off and
free shipping to get this special offer
text the word ben to 64 000 that has
been 264 000 tech spends 64 000 today
paint your life celebrate the moments
that matter most terms apply available
at painterlife.com again text ben to 64
000 to get started alrighty so supreme
court had its oral arguments on friday
and i will say that there are some
distinctions between the justices the
conservative justices still care about
the constitution of the united states
they still care about things like
enabling statutes and the limits on them
and the administrative state and how far
the administrative state can go they
still care about things like the major
questions doctrine they still care
about the federalism that is implicit in
the constitution of the united states
and is actually written into the
structure of it they see the difference
between a local government and federal
government the folks on the left not so
much so they're really three left-wing
justices on the court at this point that
would be elena kagan just as stephen
breyer and sonia sotomayor
justice breyer is a is a
far left figure
but justice breyer's basic take is that
he likes the policy and he thinks that
the osha statute is big enough to maybe
squeeze it in okay that is justice
breyer's view elena kagan's view is
slightly different she she also says she
she likes the policy and therefore the
policy is is kind of good
but she has a little bit more politics
to it which is that she will shift the
nature of the constitution to meet the
policy and then you have so sonya
sotomayor who is just dumb i'm sorry
she's a low iq human being sonya
sotomayor is a fool
and kagan is not stupid breyer is not
stupid
sonya sotomayor is dumb she's a very
stupid person so sonia sotomayor was
explicitly selected because again this
is one of the problems with the sort of
affirmative action approach of the left
to politics they selected sonia
sotomayor because she was latina not
just latina she had said she is a wise
latina she said in a speech in 2001 at
the university of california berkeley
law school quote
i would hope that a wise latina woman
with the richness of her experiences
would more often than not reach a better
conclusion than a white male who hasn't
lived that life
of course that is asinine the basic
notion of constitutional law is that the
constitution is available to reason for
any human being and that you do not
bring your personal life experiences to
bear on the constitution instead the
constitution is a series of words that
have meanings and those meanings can be
interpreted with by anyone who has a
prefrontal cortex but she had boiled it
down into a sort of racial essentialism
that you see in critical race theory and
this came up at her confirmation
hearings she was confirmed nonetheless
in any case sonia sotomayor said some of
the dumbest stuff i have ever heard at a
supreme court hearing this was posted
online the audio was available online to
listen to and it was just insane so here
is sonia sotomayor just saying crazy
nonsense about
the about the vax mandate and about the
state of covid in our society generally
we have hospitals that are almost at
full capacity with people is severely
ill on ventilators we have over a
hundred thousand children which we've
never had before in in serious condition
and
many on ventilators
um
no
that is not true those stats are just
completely specious just made them up
she pulled them directly out of her
colon i don't know what she's listening
to not even msnbc is reporting that
because it's simply not true in fact she
got fact checked four pinocchios from
glenn kessler at the washington post
yeah i mean that that was such a bad and
stupid remark that even rachelle
willenski the cdc had to try sonia
sotomayor for being so wildly off here
was rachelle wolenski from the cdc being
like yeah that's not true
we can find from friday suggests there
are fewer than 3 500 current pediatric
hospitalizations from covet 19. is that
true
yeah but you know here's what i can tell
you about our pediatric hospitalizations
now first of all the vast majority of
children who are in the hospital are
unvaccinated
okay first of all
she tries to immediately swivel to the
unvaccinated children okay the fact is
the children who are getting very very
sick from covet have serious
pre-existing conditions in the first
place as a general rule again according
to the cdc that is her organization
fewer than 700 children have died since
the beginning of the pandemic from
covenant 19 and that includes all the
people who are massively
immunocompromised or have serious
underlying health conditions the grand
total number of kids who are completely
healthy who have died of coca-19 is
still in the low double digits
in any case sonya starts me are
completely off base but based on her
completely inane understanding of kovid
she thinks this is a good idea and that
combines with her completely inane
understanding of the constitution which
is to say she does not understand it
here she was on friday explaining she
literally does not understand the
difference between a local government
and a federal government in the
constitutional structure which is like
first year law school and or spending
two minutes or beyond with the
constitution of the united states
if it's within the police power to
protect the health
and welfare of workers
you seem to be saying the states can do
it
but you're saying the federal government
can't
even though it's facing
the same crisis in interstate commerce
that states are facing within their own
borders
i am not sure i understand the
distinction why the states would have
the power
but the federal government wouldn't
um because the states have more power
than the federal government with regard
to regulations like this and have had
since the beginning of the republic
that's the answer
you know like if you want in fact i
would recommend to justice sota mayor
that if she wants a full list of the
things that the federal government can
do it's in this document we call it the
constitution of the united states it's a
full list of what the government is
allowed to do
and everything that's not in that list
is something the government is not
allowed to do right that was the
original concept of the constitution
it's right there in the text so i'd
recommend that you take a look at it but
again this just shows the wild
disconnect between members of the left
and the constitution so she i'm not even
sure she's read it i mean it's
incredible or if she has it's been a
very very long time because it's
completely irrelevant to her and then
there's elena kagan so elena kagan's
take is slightly different which is this
policy is just really good and because i
like this policy and is really geared
towards stopping all of this that means
that it must be justifiable i'll find
some constitutional hook to hang my hat
on so she's not going to spew outright
this information the way that sonya
sotomayor does because again i know
justice kagan she was the dean of the
law school when i was at harvard law
she's not a stupid person she's just a
very motivated thinker so here's elena
kagan talking about the beauty of the
vax mandate
why isn't this necessary to abate a
grave risk
this is a pandemic in which nearly a
million people have died
it is by far
the greatest public health danger that
this country
uh has faced in the last century
more and more people are dying every day
more and more people are getting sick
every day i don't mean to be dramatic
here i'm just sort of stating facts
and this is the policy
that
is um most geared
to stopping all this
okay uh it is not the policy most geared
towards stopping all this in fact the
evidence that this is the policy most
geared towards stopping all this does
not exist because it doesn't it doesn't
stop all this by the way it is not true
that more and more americans are dying
every day in fact the the number of
americans who've been dying every day
has basically stagnated on a day on day
level and we've already hit the peak of
this as the information suggests
meanwhile justice prior are doing the
same thing right the idea is it's so bad
it's so bad it's so bad that any policy
we decide to slap on it is good and so
this is politics this has nothing did
you hear a constitutional argument there
at all was there anything remotely about
the constitution what elena kagan was
saying so for so to mayor the
constitution just does not exist for
kagan it exists but we have to ignore it
in times of emergency justice briar is
kind of along the same lines
three-quarters of a million new cases
yesterday
that's ten times as many
as when osha put this ruling is that
what you're doing now to say it's in the
public interest in this situation to
stop this vaccination rule with
nearly a million new cases every day i
mean to me i would find that
unbelievable
you would find that unbelievable except
for the fact that the grand number of
new cases they are much much much milder
and again it completely undercuts this
case because if the idea is that the
vaccines were supposed to stop
transmission then why would vax mandate
do anything in the face of omicron when
clearly they did not stop transmission
again their entire case has been wrecked
by omicron omicron has completely
destroyed whatever case there was on a
rational level but it's not about
rationality for the left wing of the
court and particularly for sotomayor for
them it's just about the government
should be able to do whatever it wants
to do and you should have no say in it
whatsoever and the constitution is no
barrier
so it used to be that the the sort of
loosest standard for constitutional
review was rational basis review the
idea was that you had to at least
demonstrate a rational reason why you
were doing what you were doing this vax
policy does not even meet that standard
because again the vaccines are not
preventing transmission
so the vax policy doesn't even meet
those standards
according to the left however there no
longer needs to be rational basis review
the question is just does the government
want to do a thing that sounds good to
me and if the answer is yes then they
get to do it at no point does the
constitution actually play a role in
this discussion meanwhile for the right
of the court it's the opposite here is
samuel alito justice alito saying uh
guys can you explain to me when osha has
ever done anything remotely like this
before
i'm not saying the vaccines are unsafe
i'm not contesting that in any way there
is a risk
right has osha ever imposed any other
safety regulation that
imposes some extra risk on the employee
okay so the point he's making here is
that typically an osha mandate is
something like you need to put on a hard
hat hard hats do not have side effects
and when ocean mandate is don't let
asbestos be in the ceiling
having asbestos in the ceiling does not
have unintended positive effects on the
people who are working there however if
you tell somebody to get a backs some
people already have natural immunity
some people may get myocarditis so
that's the point that he is making
meanwhile amy coney barrett asks i think
an even more important question which is
is there any limiting principle here
whatsoever when does the emergency end
when you get to say that osha does not
have this power what exactly can't osha
do if the idea is that osha is allowed
to do whatever it can to mitigate risk
not of transmission anymore but to
mitigate risk of people getting sicker
than they normally would what can't osha
do
when does the emergency end i mean a lot
of this argument has been about
congress's failure to act
two years from now do we have any reason
to think that covid will be gone or that
new variants might not be emerging and
when when must osha actually resort to
its regular authority and go through
notice and comment and not simply be
kind of doing it um in this quick way
which doesn't afford people the voice in
the process that they're otherwise
entitled to
see this this would be the question okay
but you never hear actual legal
questions from the left wing of the
court which just demonstrates once again
that the supreme court for the left is
just another tool of policy for the
right they actually seem to care about
the constitution which is why sometimes
you get the right ruling and ways that
the right doesn't like the right of the
court will sometimes rule in ways that
the right would not prefer because they
will say that this violates basic
constitutional precepts because the role
of the supreme court is different from
the role of the legislature it just
boils down once again to the fact that
for the left everything is politics and
for the right not everything is politics
already in just one second we'll get to
the left maintaining that the true
threat to elections is the right
meanwhile saying that illegal immigrants
should vote it's pretty astonishing
stuff first with the ever increasing
number of car makes and models it's
pretty impossible to stock all the parts
you need in a traditional chain
storefront so something breaks in your
car and you head on over to the local
auto parts store and you ask them for
the part they are probably not gonna
have it they're probably gonna have to
order it online and then up charge you
for the pleasure instead why not just
skip the middleman and go directly to
rockauto.com you've got it at home
you've got it in your pocket why would
you choose to spend 30 50 100 more for
the exact same auto parts at a chain
store or a new car dealership
for example a delphi fg 1456 fuel pump
assembly for a 2005 to 2010 honda
odyssey is 353 bucks at advance and 216
bucks at rockauto.com so why not save
money and save time rockauto.com it's a
family business serving auto parts
customers online for 20 years head on
over to rockauto.com shop for auto and
body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers they've got everything
from engine control modules and brake
parts to tail lamps motor oil and even
new carpet whether it's for your classic
or daily driver get everything you need
and a few easy clicks delivered directly
to your door that rockauto.com catalog
is unique it's remarkably easy to
navigate you can quickly see all the
parts available for your vehicle and
choose the brands specifications and
prices you prefer best of all the prices
are really really low go to rockauto.com
right now see all the parts available
for your car or truck and write shapiro
in there how did you hear about us box
so they know that we sent you already in
just one second we'll get to new york
city granting voting rights to
non-citizens
wow we'll get to that in a moment first
when everyone else is kneeling some
people have the courage to stand alone
one of those men is nba star jonathan
isaac who despite facing heavy criticism
from the media for his views on social
issues and vaccines over the past few
years he still stood strong i am super
pumped to announce that we have decided
to do a book with jonathan and jonathan
has decided to do a book with us it is
called why i stand jonathan's book will
be about the rise of his basketball
career his journey into faith his
strength to stand alone in the face of
immense pressure check out this teaser
the orlando magic's 23 year old starting
forward is deeply religious and proudly
unvaccinated on friday isaac got
attention for choosing not to kneel in
unison with his teammates or to wear a
black lives matter shirt my name is
jonathan isaac i play for the orlando
magic
and i'm writing a book with the daily
wire
[Music]
coverage does not mean the absence of
fear and in today's day there are so
many things that you can be afraid of
facing because of believing what you
believe or deciding to stand for what
you believe in and i believe this book
gives you a blueprint of my story of how
christ has made the difference in my
life from a young kid who struggled with
fear anxiety
self-insecurity to a man willing to
stand for what he believes
[Music]
jonathan's book is going to be one of
the very first under the daily wires new
publishing arm dw books we could not be
happier to have him on board the book is
available right now for pre-order at
amazon it's a great book jonathan is
truly an american hero john i mean talk
about somebody who stood up to pressure
while the rest of the nba was kneeling
to protest supposed systemic american
racism jonathan isaacs was standing and
he was standing with the american flag
go pick up a copy of your book today
over at amazon go check it out why i
stand you're listening to the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
[Music]
all right so meanwhile the left has
spent the last week suggesting that
democracy in america is in danger and
it's in danger because of those evil
republicans and their willingness to
throw out votes and overthrow election
processes ezra klein has an entire
article in the new york times talking
about the evils of republicans his book
his piece is titled steve bannon is on
to something why because steve bannon
has talked about the fact that
republicans need to do politics locally
so ezra klein says there are people for
the democrats working on a plan b
this week i half-jokingly asked ben
wickler the chairman of the wisconsin
democratic party what it felt to be like
on the front lines of protecting
american democracy
he replied to dead serious by telling me
what it was like he spends his days
obsessing over mayoral races in twenty
thousand person towns because those
mayors appoint the city clerks who
decide whether to pull the drop boxes
for mail-in ballots and small changes to
electoral administration could be the
difference between winning senator ron
johnson's seat in 2022 and having a
chance at democracy reform and losing
the race and the senate wickler is
organizing volunteers to staff phone
banks to recruit people who believe in
democracy to serve as municipal poll
workers because steve bannon has made it
his mission to recruit people who don't
believe in democracy to serve as
municipal poll workers
and then ezra klein says that the right
is suddenly very good at local politics
which is kind of shocking considering
that the right has been terrible at
local politics for at least two
generations and probably longer in any
case notice how ezra klein characterizes
this if you are a democratic mayoral
candidate and you want to put drop boxes
which are inherently less verifiable
than for example pulling boots if you
want to do that this makes you
pro-democracy if you don't want the drop
boxes because you fear that those are
coveted temporary
installations that should go away so you
should actually have to go in and
register to vote you should actually
have to show your id for example this
means that you are bad and the left
wants to broaden out the number of
people who can vote and they want to get
rid of a lot of the voter verification
methods that republicans have been
pursuing
ezra klein says the republicans are
trying to suppress the vote quote voter
suppression is having is happening at
every level of government here in
georgia says representative nikima
williams who chairs the georgia
democratic party we have 159 counties
and so 150 59 different ways boards of
elections are elected and elections are
carried out so we have 159 different
leaders who control election
administration in the state we've seen
those boards restrict access by changing
the number of ballot boxes often our
black members on these boards are being
pushed out well i mean you'd have to
show that they're being pushed out
because they're black and not just
because they disagree with you that all
the kovic coveted pandemic
procedures which were supposed to be
temporary are now being gotten rid of
and that that's somehow some sort of
horrible thing for democracy again none
of these things the democrats are now
talking about is deeply necessary for
the business of democracy were present
in 2008 when barack obama swamped the
ballot boxes and won a blowout election
and then won re-election in 2012. none
of this stuff existed
but according to ezra klein we have to
rig the election so they don't rig the
elections is basically the idea this is
how much we care about democracy is that
we need to put in place all of these
procedures that are less verifiable
so he he quotes a couple of particular
cases he says gabriela cesares kelly was
a member of the tejano odom nation
agreed to staff a voting registration
booth at a community college where she
worked in pima county arizona she was
stunned to hear the stories of her
students we keep blaming students for
not participating but it's really
complicated to get registered to vote if
you don't have a license the nearest dmv
is an hour and a half away and you don't
own a car she said well somehow 155
million americans came up with the
ability to vote in the last election
cycle
so instead she decided that she was
going to
work on specifically following up with
specific people so for example the
example she gives is that certain people
who work for the county recorder's
office could work with the postmaster's
office to put registration forms in
tribal postal offices or not when it
called to voters to vote or verify a
ballot and heard an answering machine in
spanish it could follow up in spanish or
not
well i mean that works in reverse as
well if you're specifically only calling
up people who have a a an answering
machine in spanish and then you only
follow up with those people it could
work that way too like again
at a certain point you're going to have
to assume that the average comes out in
the wash you have some
board of election advisers or democrats
some who are republicans and it mainly
comes out in the wash but this is why
it's so amazing to hear the left
complain that the right is undermining
elections while they consistently
undermine the veracity of elections if
we don't get our way the election is
corrupt if we if by the way again this
would have happened in 2020 if donald
trump had won the left would have been
the one riding if this was the great
fear leading up to the 2020 election
the great fear leading up to 2020 is
that if the donald trump had been
declared winner on november 4th just go
back in time and you'll remember this
and there'd be widespread riots across
the united states
january 6th is the best thing ever to
happen to the left because it was a
right-wing riot
okay but the real worry leading up to
january leading up to november 4th
leading up to the election was that if
democrats didn't get their way they
would declare the election illegitimate
and blame the postmaster general and
blame trump for for rigging the ballot
boxes and blame people like brad
raffensberger in georgia for rigging the
thing after all democrats have been
claiming this since 2000 now the
giveaway is pretty obvious here the
giveaway is that in new york city
democrats have now made it possible for
one million non-citizens to vote
so if you are worried about democrats
broadening the votes of people who
really should not be voting they're kind
of doing it in broad daylight in new
york city according to breitbart up to 1
million non-citizens living in new york
city will have access to the ballot box
after mayor eric adams on sunday
approved legislation by the city council
to automatically become law so in other
words a bunch of people who are not
actually
bound by american law because they're
illegal immigrations
because they're illegal immigrants
a bunch of people who are not paying for
example federal income tax unless they
have stolen a social security number
those folks now get to vote in local
elections in new york city
adam said in a statement i believe new
yorkers should have a say in their
government which is why i have and will
continue to support this important
legislation i have a question what's the
limiting principle why wouldn't
democrats nationally think this applies
why wouldn't they be attempting to get
maybe 15 20 million illegal immigrants
in the in the country currently to just
have the vote
and and why is that not some sort of
corruption of the electoral process
if millions and millions of americans
who are voting based on the fact that
they pay income tax and are subject to
all of the nation's laws and then you
have tens of millions of people who
theoretically the democrats would want
to vote
while they don't pay full federal income
tax for example
eric adams said well i initially had
some concerns i had a productive
dialogue with my colleagues in
government to put those concerns at ease
i believe allowing the legislation to be
enacted is by far the best choice and
look forward to bringing millions more
into the democratic process according to
the left the way that the democratic
process works is that the democratic
process
is all about every single human whether
they ought to vote or not being allowed
to vote
more than a dozen communities across the
united states already allow non-citizens
to cast ballots in local elections
including 11 towns in maryland and two
in vermont
measure enables non-citizens who have
been lawful permanent residents of the
city for at least 30 days
30 days as well as those authorized to
work in the u.s including so-called
dreamers to help select the city's mayor
city council members borough presidents
comptroller and public advocate i think
all those folks are going to be in favor
of strict immigration law
now the suggestion that democrats are in
favor of allowing a lot of people to
enter the country illegally so they can
shift the voting it's hard to see how
these folks are very much in favor of
american citizens having priority in the
vote when they are literally
prioritizing non-american citizens
voting in local elections
and the idea that shoring up elections
is a high priority to democrats is
obviously untrue
the right has been suggesting now for
months something called a revision of
the electoral count act do you remember
the electoral count act of 1887
is kind of vague in its specifics it
allowed for a bunch of confusion inside
the right wing particularly in 2020 over
whether the vice president of the united
states could simply reject votes now the
answer was no but the eca is kind of
unclear
according to dan mclaughlin writing for
the national review the eca's current
language represents the chief point of
vulnerability that turned donald trump's
campaign against the 2020 election into
a riot at the capitol last january 6th
the two most alarming aspects of the
aftermath of 2020 were closely related
one was trump's effort to pressure state
governors state legislatures mike pence
and members of congress to reject biden
electors chosen by statewide popular
vote and substitute trump electors
chosen by state legislatures a revised
eca could address this particular danger
and avoid a repeat of last january 6th
in future elections it would do so by
clarifying that the vp cannot
unilaterally reject electors by
precluding states that select electors
by popular vote from refusing after the
fact to recognize electors chosen by
that vote and by raising the vote
thresholds to make objections to
electors and reject state of electors
slates of electors certified by a state
governor right so this could be cleared
up so you would imagine that democrats
would want to support that right i mean
it would prevent things like the
argument that the election was
illegitimate and that you could have
alternative slates of electors created
by state legislatures like they should
be in favor of this right nope kamala
harris came out against it over the
weekend here is vp harris
because it's not a solution to the
problem at hand which is that
right now in the united states of
america we need federal laws
that guarantee
the freedom and right of every american
to have access to the ballot to be able
to vote the john lewis voting rights act
the freedom to vote act address that
issue and those are the issues that are
are present and that are imminent and
that are
really dispositive frankly of this
moment in time in terms of whether we
are going to fight for some of the most
important pillars of a democracy such as
the freedom to she's ridiculous okay
these people are ridiculous they clearly
are not interested in the pillars of
democracy they don't even want to reform
the electoral count act to prevent the
kind of arguments that trump was making
post november 4th they don't care about
democracy they want illegal immigrants
to vote and they don't care about
reforming the eca all they want is to
reform the voting procedures to allow
for more people to vote illegally to
allow for the possibility of voter fraud
and to essentially corrupt the voting
procedures across the nation through
things like ballot harvesting that's
what they actually want and if they
don't get their way they say that
democracy is being undermined it just
demonstrates how full of absolute crap
they are already we'll be back here
later today with an additional hour of
content in the meantime go check out our
newest podcast morning wire on today's
episode they report a new study showing
how the pandemic is impacting babies
that episode is available right now on
apple spotify or wherever you listen to
podcast so make sure to tune in i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feldt executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover and our production manager
is pavo wiedowski associate producer
bradford carrington editing is by adam
scievent audio is mixed by mike
hair and makeup is by fabiola cristina
production assistant jessica crand the
ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2022
john bickley here daley wire editor in
chief wake up every morning with our
show morning wire on today's episode
teachers resign amid ongoing coveted
controversies a new study shows how the
pandemic is impacting babies
an unvaccinated novak djokovic squares
off against the australian government
join us and get the facts first on the
news you need to know with our show
morning wire